en roulant pendant deux heures vers le
nord à partir de montréal on se retrouve
au coeur des forêts de lanaudière le
givre sur les branches a beau donner une
touche de blanc à la nature au paradis
québécois de motoneige il n'y a pas
encore donné j'ai toute la région
réal massé nous a fait visiter sa
pourvoirie fréquentée essentiellement
par les motoneigistes en hiver bien
charles vi et de votre adresse et à sud
est comme ça un montage à 15 heures de
15 en avant de sa part tout au tout
depuis quatre ans des failles on est
décalé d'un gros lourd comme il faut 30
centimètres de neige pour faire de la
motoneige
il craint que tout le mois de décembre
soit gâchée germain de cassure à
l'auberge g19 chalet mais ça normalement
c'est à guichet fermé et l'homme
solitaire de sessegon cher monsieur jean
les gens nulle l'apatar étonnant
monsieur en mal de fonds de 15 cents
mille de semaine c'est si incroyable
réal massé n'est pas au bout de ses
peines
hiver tardif et redoux pourrait devenir
la norme
on devrait assister à une réduction de
12 de l'enneigement au cours de la
saison hivernale qui va même devenir
maître à risque pour certaines régions
du québec la période du temps des fight
à quelques kilomètres de la pourvoirie
de réal massé le copropriétaire de
l'auberge du vieux moulin à tan
plusieurs groupes de français à partir
de lundi ils viennent pour la motoneige
la pêche blanche la raquette j'imagine
que je vais être obligée d'annuler ce
soit dans l'est dans les jours qui vont
venir nous c'est juste qu'on voit
assumer ses pertes la et puis plus les
pertes des frais d'annulation des
billets d'avion violent ça serait notre
première saison aussi désastreuse il
s'attend à perdre 50 à 75 mille dollars
ce qui nous porte peut-être à changer
nos méthodes de vente peut-être de
repousser ces séjours l'ovaire janvier
début janvier mi-janvier qui peut
toujours est incertain
plus au sud vendredi au centre de ski du
mont saint bruno
il a fait jusqu'à 14 degrés sur les
quatre pistes de neige artificielle
ouverte quelques dizaines de skieurs et
planchistes descendait entre les plaques
de gazon
d'habitude quand on parle de sport parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de neige sauf que la
strauss kahnie ce que j'ai pas le goût
de la politique
le début de saison est un moment
névralgique pour les abonnements de
saison
c'est certain que ya un retard on va
aller chercher souvent de 10 à 15% du
chiffre d'affaires de l'entreprise
jusqu'à 30 % de pertes potentielles si
cette météo se poursuit tout le mois de
décembre
mais michel couture se console avec ses
canons à neige qui ne prennent qu'une
semaine pour enneiger la station au
complet sauf qu'aujourd'hui il ne fait
même pas assez froid pour les faire
fonctionner et c'est rare piste qui
était ouverte à saint-bruno sont
maintenant fermés
habituellement à une semaine avant noël
on commence à monter la glace les
dizaines de patinoire municipale de
montréal comptent aussi parmi les
victimes des hivers doux et tardif on
évalue que trois semaines de moins par
rapport à llo dix ans pour la période de
glace extérieure donc il y aura un
impact dont l'avenir selon le maire de
rosemont petite patrie
les arrondissements pourrait devoir
diminuer le nombre de patinoires pour
réduire les coûts d'entretien soit qu'on
va vers le choix que toronto a fait
c'est à dire de mettre des glace
réfrigérée extérieur pour maintenir une
plus longue période de patinage à
l'extérieur ou simplement on va accepter
le fait qu' on va peut-être pâti d'un
jour une un mois par année pour les uns
revoir les façons de faire pour les
autres
revoir le modèle d'affaires il faudra
s'adapter à dame nature
il faut regarder aussi être vos continue
à briller qu'il faut pas qu'il y ait un
bras parce que j'en voyais plus mal